some other exciting news jessica and
justin reportedly
welcome their second child have you had
a chance to say
congratulations at all
well of course yeah we uh i've talked
very you know several times and of
course uh
we knew it before anyone else did so
yeah we've uh
it's been a fun celebration and they're
they're very very happy
what was the last thing that you guys
talked about in the insync
chat obviously it's not touring or doing
anything no new music
uh no it's all it's all about babies you
know it's all about the new one that
they just brought in so uh yeah it's all
about conversations about a newborn
is is the baby so cute do you know the
name
uh i can i'm not gonna tell that name
good question but there's no way he
would he would kill me
all right but the baby's cute
of course i'm gonna look it's just in a
justice baby of course it is
i have a lot to talk to you about so
let's start with the daily podcast
you have been doing this every single
day i think that you're
over 200 episodes now 250 episodes
yeah we're about 250 now yeah wow okay
what is it like to do that in quarantine
i mean is there much of a
difference it has been a lifesaver you
know i did uh i had a serious extend
show for five years and it was a daily
show drive home show and it was
it was a lot to have to do that two
hours live every day
with podcasts it's just been amazing and
thank goodness i started
this show right before lockdown because
if i didn't have this
every day i would have been going crazy
at home
because like i said all of my all my
projects are on hold right now so
this has really just kept me going it's
been nice to be able to
talk to the fans out there and and it's
just been
it's been a godstone for sure do you
feel like you are constantly
racking your brain trying to figure out
what can i talk about today or do you
feel like there is so much to talk about
because of what's happening well it's
crazy because we were the first
daily uh entertainment news podcast
well because of the lockdown and no
entertainment happening hardly
it really changed during this pandemic
where
and now everyone is at home so all these
celebrities are
easily you know gettable on zoom
so it went from a show of i didn't
really have that many interviews it was
just me and my peanuts it was just a
funny show
to now every single show we have a
hard-hitting
interview um so it has changed and
there's tons of content out there now
just because
everyone's at home and and very
available
is there a dream celebrity that you're
trying to book right now
yeah um yes actually uh there's there's
a lot of dream ones i'm
i'm developing um some shows right now
i'm actually
starting my own podcast uh vertical and
so i get to
help produce a lot of different podcasts
for different other people uh which i'm
super excited about and
a lot of things that i'll be able to uh
announce
in the future um but yeah there's one
show that we're developing called
lance's legends and uh and it's
basically
a very you know sit down here's you know
this is your life type interview
with my favorite legends living legends
right now so you're talking about
carol burnett and garth brooks um you
know christian chenoweth
i mean there's there's so many on my
list that i cannot donahue i mean people
that really
you know affected my life and are
legends to me